merci la parole est à madame dire gêné
dubé l'ulr le seul premier ministre
avec dix neuf mille naissances de moins
qu'en 2014 2015 puis l'année la plus
faible pour la natalité française depuis
20 ans un résultat qui reflète
assurément le manque d'ambition de votre
politique familiale alors que le projet
de loi de finances pour 2010 est ce vous
offrait une dernière occasion de
rattrapage car la famille française a
été particulièrement malmenées au cours
de votre quinquennat
votre bilan est explicite 3,2 millions
de familles majoritairement des classes
moyennes ont subi depuis quatre ans
votre matraquage fiscal la baisse des
prestations et des aides à la garde et
la fin de l'universalité des allocations
familiales avec le versement de la prime
de naissance seulement trois mois après
l'arrivée de l'enfant
vous ne prenez pas en compte le besoin
d'équipement en amont des familles
vous avez créé seulement en dix sept
mille neuf cent soixante places en
crèche soit moins de 20% de celles
promises pendant ce temps le nombre
d'enfants gardés par une assistante
maternelle a reculé de 16 mille cinq
cents places
résultat les parents davantage recours à
la crèche qui est pourtant un mode de
garde plus coûteux pour les
collectivités on comprend pourquoi deux
français sur trois désapprouve la
politique familiale du gouvernement et
le problème lesieu premier ministre
c'est que les perspectives en 2010 est
son pire encore avec l'impact négatif de
la mauvaise réforme du congé parental
pour les moins de 2 ans avec la
situation financière catastrophique des
collectivités locales qui ne peuvent
plus financer de nouvelles places en
crèche et se retrouve parfois même a
annulé certains projets et enfin avec
l'âge moyen des assistantes maternelles
qui ne cesse d'augmenter
au total des millions de familles
verront leur est belle si à 2017
monsieur le premier ministre comment
assumer ce bilan désastreux qui empêche
bien souvent les femmes de concilier vie
familiale et vie professionnelle
quand comprendrez-vous enfin que la
famille
doit rester le pilier de nos sociétés
modernes merci la parole est à madame
laurence rossignol ministre dé famille
de l'enfance et des droits des femmes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
virginie du mineur d'abord peut-être
pouvons-nous demander quel est le sens
d'une politique familiale pour moi le
sens une politique familiale c'est à la
fois de s'adapter aux évolutions des
familles et de ré un style est toujours
davantage de justice sociale
et ce n'est pas de promouvoir un type de
famille un modèle de famille en
utilisant les prestations familiales
dans ce but la politique familiale que
nous avons mise en place est une
politique familiale a laissé bouche bée
pour la dernière de la gare nous avons
d'abord fait progresser les conditions
de vie des familles les plus modestes et
également des familles monoparentales
étrangement absente d'ailleurs de votre
discours sur les familles les familles
monoparentales qui sont 20% aujourd'hui
des familles 35 % dans certains
quartiers grâce à notre politique
familiale au vu des prestations
nouvelles comme la garantie d un pied de
pension alimentaire qui est une violence
économique faite aux femmes et nous
mettrons en place au 1er janvier 2017
l' agence de recouvrement vous évoquez
des coupes dans la politique familiale 5
% des foyers fiscaux 9 % des
allocataires des allocations familiales
ont effectivement vu leur prestation
baissé et on contribue davantage à la
solidarité pour 2 millions de familles
qui ont au contraire vu les aides aux
familles augmenté soixante dix mille
places de crèches supplémentaires 70
milles nous sommes le seul pays d'europe
à concilier un taux de natalité élevé
avec un taux d'activité professionnelle
des femmes aussi élevé et madame du lit
muller vous ne pouvez pas quand même
expliquer aux français que une réforme
celle de la modulation mise en place au
1er juillet 2015 a eu un impact immédiat
sur le taux de natalité de l'année 2015
je ne veux pas donner un cours de
sciences naturelles mais ce n'est pas
possible
donc et puis par ailleurs et enfin c'est
très méprisant à l'égard des familles
que de penser que pour 60 euros par mois
des familles pourraient renoncer à faire
des ans merci madame
[Applaudissements]